so it's lunchtime in New York City I
just heard about this burger place that
sells one of if not the biggest burger
in New York City so I figured I'd grab a
few friends see if real efficient Hey
[Applause]
so this is Clinton hall and they have a
burger challenge
that is huge there's fries and a beer
and you have to finish all of it wait I
didn't know better beer but you have to
finish all you're excited about you also
have to do in 25 minutes I personally do
not care about the 25 minutes all I care
about is that I more than you I think
I'm gonna win this I would be shocked
when she beat either one I would see why
can't just advise the normal lunches
yeah
I think like everything I said all about
everything this is why I didn't make any
bold statements earlier like this
this girl here you know you want that
alright so there are literally just
burgers yeah blonde threads three
burgers three big burgers almost doctor
doctor you like juicy patty burger I can
feel my arteries just slowly closing up
on me I'm gonna open it up and like yeah
I'm on this way down yet I just finished
the first one before you guys oh okay
right there girl I do I get a prize so
Rob right now is at the winning pace
insert shot at the pizza challenge
that's the dude hits are you party here
first
nope
now I'm gonna kind of get into it I'm
feeling my confidence is coming in I'm
pretty good though right
oh she here no no no what
normally I eat over the sink or in
sweatpants but do you live in jail yeah
I'm still feeling good I'm starting to
slow down but the fries are gonna be
difficult they think I can't really
think anymore I might start crying
nobody would be sure as hell not this
one just wait though I might be like The
Tortoise and the hare you're powering do
you think that do you believe that see
Chisholm ran off to let me live
no the burger
[Music]
slowing Oh I'm sure some people out
there could probably finish this all in
Christian just my button there's a lot
of fries here it is oh I'm hurt feeling
it
so I think we've all maxed out and where
we are loser again I have five fries
that I didn't the fried oil might not
look like it made two whole burgers he
put that there Oh what have you hit go
to the I literally variant here cat to
the Clinton Hall challenge for
forgetting the bedroom all yeah yeah we
know
[Laughter]
[Music]
me dying in my food goodbye summer bod
yeah goodbye yeah I'm not gonna get be
in a bikini not not in this BuzzFeed
video